l'odeur du café qui réveille les parfums
de la cuisine de notre enfance pourquoi
certains aiment la coriandre et d'autre
la déteste le goût c'est une histoire de
perception
[Musique]
lorsque on déguste des aliments on a
d'un côté la perception gustative donc
avec la langue on a de l'autre côté la
perception olfactive mais on a aussi la
perception de la texture la perception
crise génial c'est à dire du piquant de
la fraîcheur on a les composantes
auditive si sa coque ou pas on à
l'aspect visuel
dans son livre une et flairer sentir
johannes france nelly explore tous les
effets des odeurs sur notre cerveau moi
j'aime bien faire la comparaison avec un
orchestre
si on écoute un orchestre il faut avoir
des violents il faut avoir des cuivres
il faut qu'il soit là avec le bon volume
et il faut vraiment qu'ils se soient
équilibrés et c'est la même chose avec
notre perception lorsque l'on mange en
aliments et les chefs sont des artistes
de tout ça
m
la chef anne desjardins a passé sa vie à
composer des plats à jouer avec les
goûts saveurs et parfums le goût aux
saisons comme généralement parlant on
parle de la bouche le qu'est-ce qu'on
veut manger mais le bout c'est aussi par
le nez le son la vue pour elle ces
éléments sont essentiels en cuisine
lorsqu'elle prépare un plat au menu
aujourd'hui un goût d'automne
champignons poêlés et courges se relit
de crème de bonnet mais j'ai choisi de
la courge j'ai choisi aussi des
champignons ici j'ai un peu de chic à
qui
j'ai une canne d'un bol est alors seul
le bol et on le reconnaît entre tous le
c'est pour ça que c'est le chili peut
c'est un parfum incomparable avec l'aîné
on a des milliards d'odeurs qui on peut
distinguer nous avons à peu près 400
récepteur différent mais c'est pas la
même chose d'une personne à l'autre vous
avez peut-être 420 moi j'ai peut-être
390 et ce n'est pas ce ne sont pas
nécessairement les mêmes capteurs que
nous avons est donc vraiment lorsque
l'on mange des aliments des boissons si
on est capable de faire des distinctions
fine c'est vraiment via lo drac et ça se
passe
disons qu'ils ont croqué dans une pomme
il va avoir des sucres de la pomme aussi
l'acidité la pomme que je vais percevoir
avec les papilles gustatives dans
quelles substances dissoutes dans la
salive mais ensuite il ya d'autres
molécules qui se retrouvent dans la
pomme sont des molécules volatiles qui
vont rentrer dans l'air et qu'ils vont
montrer par en arrière dans mon pharynx
et vent monte dans la cavité nasale et
je vais les percevoir avec mon nez
tellement
ça sent le champignon non je sens
beaucoup le cheetah qui se sortent
champignons qui a partiellement une
odeur de kembs à l'acidité je trouve
quand même que le teint vieillesse ou 20
met en valeur les perf 1 de boisés
c'est des saveurs qui sont longs ou ses
études et les goûts des odeurs
je fais la différence entre les odeurs
fulbert ce qu'on nous trompe bédénik
orient puis les aux dents longues comme
le romarin
la coriandre quoique fugace peut
toutefois incommodé ou carrément
déplaire à certains dont l'exemple de la
coriandre il vient un récepteur de la
coriandre si on a cet récepteur dans
notre répertoire alors la coriandre va
avoir une odeur ou un goût de savon et
va devenir désagréable si on n'a pas ce
capteur la c7 récepteur là à ce moment
là la coriandre va avoir une odeur
beaucoup plus agréable d'autres éléments
expliquent aussi noah version de
préférence ou nos sensibilités latentes
envers l'odeur est un facteur
déterminant
on a donné fromage parmesan à nos
participants à son képi on a demandé
vous allez sentir du fromage parmesan
est ce que c'est agréable ils ont dit
oui j'ai relativement agréable sur
l'échelle de sa voix disent peut-être
6,7 et plus tard on est revenu avec
l'odeur de parmesan mais maintenant la
présenter avec une autre étiquette
l'étiquette était vont me sécher et
c'était la même odeur mais les gens
lorsqu'ils sentaient cette odeur avec la
tente que ceux du vomi sécher il
trouvait ça très désagréable donc 0.1
sur 10
donc vous voyez c'est vraiment la tente
que nous avons envers une odeur qui va
déterminer si on aime ou pas un peu
comme un musicien ses notes et c'est
exactement quel nom qu'est ce qu'elle va
faire comme ça même en années le
cuisinier et même pas besoin d'avoir une
piste sous la pluie ici ce que ça goûte
[Musique]
le bol est très long en bouche une
goutte non mais j'ai une sensation
vraiment deux champignons plein la
bouche la courge et levier remplir cette
saveur savait qu'on aime de la courge
musquée opus créé douze fils paul le
ténor gamme essence on ne veut vraiment
comme des petits accents à ce moment là
c'est comme écouter une symphonie
lorsqu'elle mange avons réparé
[Musique]